you
may be able to help solve a mystery
[Music]
the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones video
in this video i will be discussing some
of the show's mysteries that i wish were
answered before everything came to an
end
as you all know millions of fans were
very upset after the show ended because
so many things were left unanswered
things that had been set up in some of
the earlier seasons
i'm not only talking about minor
references either i'm talking about
things that were mentioned over and over
again
season after season one of the things i
really wish they would have answered
before the show
ended was what did varys here in the
flames we first heard about this very
early on in this series
and every single time varys brought it
up you could see how much of an effect
it had on him
when we see varys first mention this to
tyrion right before the battle of
blackwater bay
he almost starts to cry when thinking
about it
you probably don't entirely trust me
don't take it personally i don't
entirely trust myself
and yet i have seen things and heard
things
things you have not things i wish i had
none
then in the very next season season
three varys finally revealed what
happened to him when he was only a child
not only did varys share this
information with tyrion but he also
revealed that he had this man locked
inside a box because varys wanted him to
suffer for what he had done
i still dream of that night
not of the sorcerer not of his blade
i dream of the voice from the flames was
it a god
a demon a conjurous trick i don't know
when i first saw that scene i would have
guaranteed varys would eventually tell
us what he heard in the flames
i know i always thought it must have
something to do with how his story would
end
it felt like this was supported even
more by what kinvara said to him in
season six
can vara more or less threaten varys by
telling him
as long as he stays loyal to daenerys he
has nothing to fear from her
you could easily see that what kinvara
was saying to varys had him visibly
shaken
she followed this up by asking him does
he want her to tell him what he heard in
the flames
when the saucer tossed your parts in the
fire
you heard a voice call out from the
flames do you remember
should i tell you what the voice said
should i tell you the name of the one
who spoke
now it seemed obvious that whatever
varus heard in the flames had a direct
connection to his endgame
but what did he actually hear
unfortunately we never found out
this was just one of the many things i
wish were answered before the end
i think melisandre must have known what
varys heard as well
because she told him he would die in
westeros just like her
speaking of melisandre this leads me to
my next thing i wish was answered before
game of thrones ended
why did melisandre go back to volantis
after she left dragonstone
so where will you go volantis good
if you don't mind my saying i don't
think you should return
to westeros i'm not sure you'd be safe
here
oh i will return dear spider now i know
we can all speculate
and make guesses about why she went
there but i wish we would have been
given a definitive answer
i think most of us thought melisandre
would come back with an army
volantis is known for having the red
temple of her lore
dedicated to the lord of light this red
temple in volantis is guarded by an army
of slave soldiers known as the fiery
hand
it seemed almost fitting that melisandre
would come back with an army of fire
soldiers
ready to face off against the night king
and his ice soldiers
but that obviously never happened i also
considered that maybe she went there to
try to restore her faith
or maybe even learn some more magic but
she didn't do that much during the long
night battle
even the things she did set on fire
through her magic only lasted for a few
minutes
i think the main reason she was there
was to meet arya again
and help guide her so she could fulfill
her destiny
i see a darkness in you
and in that darkness eyes staring back
at me
brown eyes blue eyes
green eyes eyes you'll shut forever
we will meet again
he sat with me again and here we are
at the end of the world
you said i'd shut many eyes forever
you were right about that too brown eyes
green eyes
and blue eyes
did melisandre really need to go all the
way back to volantis to figure this out
i don't think so she clearly remembered
saying this to arya on her own
i think they might have had other ideas
in mind for melisandre but for whatever
reason they decided to go in another
direction
but even this is only a guess i wish our
old friend helen reed
would have shown up as well i have
mentioned this in another video before
but i would have loved for him to have
shown up in the later seasons to
hopefully drop some major
bombshells about different events
throughout westerosi history
he was always such a loyal friend to ned
stark even jojen reed told bran
the day ned stark died was the first
time he had seen his father cry
when i told my father about your father
the first time in my life i saw him cry
your father is hallandri yeah
save my father's life you would think
that he would have shown up when the
starks needed him most
where was he during the battle of the
bastards where was he during the long
night battle for winterfell
where was he when all the high lords and
ladies came to king's landing when bran
was named king
there were a few unfamiliar faces there
but none of them stood up and declared
themselves as helen reed
the loyal supporter of house stark
george r.r martin has always said
helen reed will show up in the books the
only reason he hasn't shown up yet is
because he knows too much information
obviously george doesn't want certain
things revealed just yet
but the show is over now and he never
appeared other than a flashback
even if they did not want to bring him
into the show they could have at least
had mira say something about what her
father was up to
all i really wanted was some indication
regarding his whereabouts
another thing i know i discussed before
is what was in those books sam stole
from the citadel
this would have been a great way for the
writers to reveal some of the answers to
the show's greatest mysteries
the citadel was known for holding so
much information
they could have got away with revealing
almost anything by just having sam
discover it in one of the books
but they never did gilly was even shown
reading a book about the long night
yet there was no mention of what was
inside that book
legends of the long night
we also saw sam looking into the
restricted area of the citadel where
books were left wide
open in those books it looked as if
there were images of the phases of the
moon
which led many of us to believe we would
find out why the seasons are so long
in this universe why do the summers last
for a decade
how were the white walkers able to bring
a winter that lasted for a generation
the answers were right there now i will
admit
it's not like sam's time at the citadel
was entirely useless
we did get confirmation about rhaegar's
annulment sam did find out about all the
dragonglass on dragonstone
and we even saw the valyrian steel
dagger and another one of the books sam
was looking at
but all that happened before sam left
the citadel
on the night that he left he went inside
the library and stole different books
that held
different information i felt like they
showed sam taking them for a very good
reason but i guess not
what about our old friend daria naharis
he was left in slaver's bay
or should i say the bay bear dragons
bring me with you let me fight for you
i can't
specific orders will be left for you
regarding the welfare of marine and the
bay of dragons
a bay of dragons we can't call it
slaver's bay anymore can we
after daenerys targaryen left for
westeros he was never mentioned again
i know that many of us thought he would
show up near the end of the series but
that never happened either
i've always wondered if he actually
stayed after daenerys left him behind
what happened to that city after she
left or even after she died
i feel like there should have been some
mention of this it was just another one
of those things left unanswered
now the number one mystery i wanted
answered the most is
who was the man the children of the
forest chose to be their weapon of mass
destruction
what made them choose him in the first
place was it random
or did he already have some sort of
magical abilities
this could have easily been answered
through one of bran stark's flashbacks
ever since i started making game of
thrones videos nearly four years ago
i've always said i thought the night
king was an ancient member of the stark
family
that's what i think makes the most sense
now imagine what kind of impact that
would have had on the story
if it were revealed that he was related
to jon bryan arya
and all the other starks for that matter
from the very beginning of the show
we saw how the starks were being set up
as the characters who would have to stop
him
in his army ever since the very first
episode
we saw brian asking ned about the white
walkers
is it trace or the white walkers
the white walkers have been gone for
thousands of years
so he was like
the madman sees what he sees
then we saw john asking his uncle benjen
if he could join the night's watch
the band of brothers who would guard the
wall from any attacks by the white
walkers
the starks were always seen as the good
guys who were simply trying to stop the
bad guys
the white walkers were shown to be this
unstoppable force
who would one day ride south on the
winds of winter to wipe out
all of human existence but the members
of house stark were not about to let
that happen they were destined to stop
them
now imagine how they would have reacted
if they found out the night king was
also a member of their family
that would have been shocking the stark
name would finally have some dirt on it
in the show
i think the writers wanted us to feel
more sympathetic to the night king
after they showed us he was just a man
who was forced into this situation
i think it would have been so much more
effective if they would have told us who
he was
or where he was from if he was from a
family like the starks who most of us
love
it would have made a bigger impact it
would have actually meant something
it would have been more of an emotional
scene if the starks found out he was one
of them
right before they had to kill him they
might not have wanted to do it
they might have tried to send him back
north after somehow fixing the wall
who knows all i do know is it would have
made things a hell of a lot more
interesting but let me know what you
think were there any mystery set up
before the final season that you wish
were answered before game of thrones
ended
let me know down below as always
i want to thank all of you for watching
this video i hope everyone has a great
day
i will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
so
you